[Musique]
l'argent stocké jusqu'au plafond
série de remplacement le bbk 2
en boîtes de 10, 20, 50 ou 100
juste au cas où la monnaie
remplacer le demag actuel
annonce incroyable de la banque fédérale
en seulement 14 jours, l'argent est versé
jusqu'au dernier coin de la république
distribuer la logistique du point de vue d'aujourd'hui
tout un exploit
[Musique]
la page presque en anglais le verso
mais complètement différent conçu autour d'eux dans le
18 mètres de distance distinguent directement
pouvoir
[Musique]
et maintenant téléphone business un contenu
à tout moment le chef actuel du
entraînement et maison de repos ska
l'un était officiellement dans l'autre
non officiel
[Musique]